[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday the 18th of
January I'm Cindy The Spectators
assistant editor and your host this week
coming up on the
show after much Ferrar the government
passed its Rwanda Bill through the
commment last night ktie B and Dr Peter
wsh will give us the latest illegal
migration isn't just a European problem
who will fix America's border crisis
I'll speak to Lono
Sher Britain is a nation famous for
boozing but are we sobering up I'll be
joined by Henry Jeff and Charles
Corin just over a year from becoming
King how has King Charles changed the
monarchy already Robert Hardman will
join me and finally what are the ethics
of War I'll be speaking tomorrow
philosopher bigger about whether
the scale of Civilian deaths in Gaza is
Justified before we get going if you
enjoy spectator TV do subscribe to our
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon so you never miss an
episode also the spectators broadcast
team is hiring if you think you could
produce this show or any of our podcasts
and want to come work with us then do
apply the deadline for applications is
the 21st of January and the link to
apply is at the bottom of this video
first up the government passed his Randa
Bill yesterday evening after Rishi sunak
faced down a group of Tory Rebels what
now for the PM's Flagship immigration
policy will illegal immigrants be
deported to Rwanda anytime soon I'm
joined Now by ktie B and Dr Peter wsh
from The Oxford migration
Observatory Katie and Peter welcome to
spectator TV now Katie after a lot of
back and forth Richie cak has managed to
pass his Rwanda bill in the Commons last
night what happened so once again we had
lots of talk from the potential Tory
Rebels about how they were willing to go
further when it came to voting at third
reading now of course we had this at
second reading when you had the ERG new
conservatives all these different groups
that Mark franois called the five
families um having these meetings having
manyi press conferences and really
trying to build it up to suggest they
could vote down the bill at second
reading of course it didn't happen but
there was the sense that if we don't get
heard in our amendments we could
actually do what we said we do before
Christmas and we could vote down the
bill at third reading now we've had
various amendments to try and toughen up
the bill um when it comes to um pushing
the limits of international law or just
breaking international law and around 60
Tory MPS voted for some of these and but
when it came to the third reading um and
of course the amendments were
unsuccessful because no one else was
voting for it um so they didn't manage
to change the bill so when it came to
the third reading and voting for The
unamended Bill there was some talk and
they were having meetings but in the end
just 11 Tory MPS voted against so a
pretty small Rebellion it was the likes
of Miriam Kate Danny Krueger from the
new conservatives you had s bravman the
former Home Secretary you had Robert
jenrich who' quit as immigration
Minister over the bill and you had Simon
Clark uh who served in the try cabinet I
don't think any of those names are that
surprising I think they have been the
ring leaders all the people who are most
Keen to be critical of rishy sunak what
was quite interesting was uh R has
suffered resignations this week um three
members of the pay rooll are gone
including Lee Anderson who was one of
his many Deputy party chairman now Lee
Anderson thought about voting against
the bill last night and I think got near
to the voting Lobby could see all the
labor politicians in there um saw them
laughing and decided it was too much and
I think that tribal sense of we are a
party it's an election year and you know
a bill and imperfect bill is better than
no bill kicked in um and he decided not
to vote against the government so I
think it's one of the reasons the
rebellion was quite low in the end and
speaking to Tor MPS today I think there
was a view of well those 11 MPS they
were in a voting uh lobby with Jeremy
Corbin and they should reflect on that
um so a small Rebellion but I would
still say a bruising week for ryck in
terms of the
headlines and and the story certainly
isn't over because Peter now the bill
goes to the Lords um but first can you
remind how is this Rwanda Bill different
from the original which the Supreme
Court slept
down well the bill um says to British
courts hey um the Supreme Court said
that Rwanda isn't safe to send people to
um but we the government say it is and
so you can have no regard to the facts
that relate to the safety of Rwanda
we're not going to test in UK courts
again the safety of Randa that's a
settled issue because the bill says
Rwanda is safe and on the Rwandan side
there also need to be some changes done
to the laws on their side too right
that's right so and this is covered by
the treaty um so the treaty you know
beefs up the safeguards and provides for
the creation of a new initial
decision-making body and a new appeals
court you'll recall that in the Judgment
of the Supreme Court that was one thing
they identified which is that even
though the randum Asylum system
has an appeals process that had never
been actually used in practice uh but
the big thing that the treaty does is it
says okay even if people are
unsuccessful in the Asylum claims they
file in Rwanda Rwanda will give them
permanent status in other words it's not
going to refo anyone it's not going to
return anyone to countries from which
they have fled and where they may be at
risk so that's what the treaty does and
it does require some input uh on the
behalf of the Rwandan government um and
actually the House of Lords committee
said that treaty should not be ratified
until we've seen sufficient buy and
sufficient progress on the Rwandan side
and also perhaps that the rwandans have
done something to enhance our trust that
they will comply with the terms of this
beefed up agreement so Katie a small
victory for rushi sunak this week but it
does seem like the road to getting a
first plane off to kagali is still quite
a long
way yes and I think it's a victory in
the sense that I think the European
research group and the other Associated
groups they look as though they are a
diminished Force if you compare it to
the brexit era Theresa May um this idea
that the Spartans would hold firm and
they're still saying well just wait
we'll be the next Spartans on this bill
but for now at least they just don't
have the numbers now I think the bigger
problem for richy sulo is effectively
does his plan work because he is now
refused to accept the Amendments um he
has ultimately said that the bill needs
no changes and he St a lot of his
reputation on that he's given a press
conference uh in which he said over to
the Lords um do not disrupt the will of
the people I think there are some MPS
who think wouldn't be the worst thing in
the world if the labor peers did disrupt
the so-called world people because then
they could at least say the reason there
aren't flights to Rwanda ahead of the
election is because of uh the labor
party um we managed to all ask things
it's on them what's their solution now I
think there is a feeling that it could
well pass the Lords at that point you're
going to get to the question of whether
it works in practice and here if the
courts are to block it or if there are
so many appeals which has been one of
the big criticisms and the right of the
party which is they're saying uh you
know the government is saying there'd
only be a very small number of relevant
cases that you could do individual
appeals on which would be successful the
writer saying actually there could be
lots and you're going to get tied in
that it's going to take months
potentially years and you're not going
to be able to get a flight to Rwanda and
therefore uh is it the case that these
this currently tiny number of rebels um
feel Vindicated come uh Easter come the
summer or is it the case that Richa is
able to get a couple of flights off to
Rwanda and I think from the government
perspective um I don't think that they
think this is the perfect solution that
is going to mean that they get flights
on mass I think the question is from
where they're starting from is it one
where you could get several flights to
Rwanda before an election and that's
probably their best case scenario if
things go right right right and P the
other bogeyman the other hurdle is the
European Court of human rights which
some Tor MPS are really uh incensed
about tell us about what happens if some
of these Deportes appeal to that Court
yeah which I'm sure would happen um the
European Court could do what it did um
when the last flight was on the tarmac
and issue an interim injunction there's
an open question about whether the
government would ignore that if it were
to ignore it then the court would surely
hold them in breach of our International
treaty obligations but once that appeal
has been sent the European Court would
be able to rule on the legality of the
policy as a whole and whether it is
compatible with the European convention
on human rights and that could
potentially Scupper the entire policy by
that stage people might have been sent
to Rwanda but if the European Court of
human rights were to say actually this
is in conflict with the European
convention then we would have to take
those people back and now Casey we we've
heard that rich sunak is not very keen
on um directly contravening the ECR so
is he just hoping that this will be a
can that he's kicking down the road and
then maybe by that time a flight's gone
off but the elections also started
anyway yeah I think this is about what
can you do in the time between now and
polling day um from from where you start
from from in the press conference after
the Bill's passed third reading Rich was
asked about these section 39 orders from
the ECR and whether he would actually
use the powers in the bill to ignore
them and he said of course I'm willing
to that's why it's in the bill but then
he was pressed on well in what
circumstances would you be willing to
ignore them and that's where I think
there's less Clarity um so uh depending
on where you sit in the party and of
course in the country your version of
when that should be ignored could be
different than what ministers really do
and I think that's one of the things you
won't know until it is in operation if
you get to that point um and I think
that is one of the areas where I think
you know it's just a proof will be in
the pudding if if he gets to the point
where the government is in a position to
choose what to do and Katie and Peter so
the Randa scheme uh planes getting off
the tarmak and into kagali not something
you'd put money on the government's own
lawers I believe have given it a coin
toss um by the next um election there
are so many moving part so I can't
really improve on that yeah I think it's
one where in government I don't think
there is a certainty and you saw that in
Rich next press conference when he was
said do you still think it is you know
can you guarantee that you will have a
flight to R before the election he
didn't say that he could guarantee it
because ultimately he can't um I think
that they're ultimately trying to get to
a point where they can say well we've
done so much to try and get there that
even if they don't H you can say well
we've done more than labor more than
others you can't say we haven't tried I
think one of the problems with the rebel
movement this week is even someon his
own party think he hasn't gone far
enough so for rishy sunk the the only I
think way out of this is for there to be
at least you know a handful of flights
to reanda otherwise uh his own party
going to turn around and say or maybe
you should have listened to some of the
figures that were telling you to do
things
differently Katie B and Dr Peter wsh
thank you so much for joining spectat
TV next is America having an ELO very
small Civil War
columnist Lono shrier writes in this
week's magazine about a standoff between
the Texas National Guard and the US
Border Patrol illegal immigration is
causing more and more problems in the
Republic she writes to tell us about it
Lio joins me now Lono Shri welcome to
spectator
TV nice to talk to you again now Lono
it's almost a cliche these days to say
that America is divided but in your
column this week you literally look at a
state that is defying the federal
government and using Force to do it tell
us about what's going on in Texas well I
defined it as a tiny Civil War because
it it is really about a state refusing
to get with the program in relation to
the federal
government uh it's a point of
consternation with border states that
the federal government is not doing its
job in policing the southern border of
the United States and
uh Governor Greg Abbott in Texas has
decided to take matters into his own
hands and in one tiny Place uh they he
has sent in the Texas National Guard
which despite the sound of it is a state
militia uh to take over uh Eagle Pass
there's a there's a park in Eagle Pass
it's a little town of only 29,000 people
um but one that regularly uh receives
something like on an average of 12,000
migrants per day which is
astonishing so uh Abbott has sent his
militia in to take over this territory
and a little bit more on on the sides uh
to try to stop illegal immigration in
that particular area um I doubt it's
very effective I think that they're not
um very successful in still in stopping
people from coming in and they have
nothing to do with these people but to
turn them over to the Border force that
um that they're keeping out so it may
just add an extra administrative level
it seems symbolic to me it's a gesture
of of rebellion um you know Circa
1860 and and the federal government is
taking uh the government
or at least the state uh to courts right
I mean they're fighting this out in the
Judiciary but it's not even the first
time that Greg Abbott has fought the
federal government in the courts oh no
this is ongoing and um Texas put up
these uh floating buoys in the Rio Grand
to try to stop people from swimming to
the
American Bank of the river and
um and the and DC sued to have them
removed um because it's the border
between two countries and that is a
federal matter DC is also suing to cut
the concertina wire that Texas has put
on the banks of that River uh to prevent
people from landing and and crawling
into the United States
um what's especially weird about this
conflict is that you would think that
the federal government and the state of
Texas would be on the same side I mean
why why aren't both parties interested
in controlling the flow of illegal
immigration into the United States it's
it's structurally and politically
bizarre well for British viewers who
might be more thinking about European
migrant crisis and not know so much
about the US side um you've kind of
hinted at it already but just how severe
are are we talking about when we talk
about this illegal migration
problem
well I hate to Boggle our viewers
minds but it's way worse than Europe
right the scale of it is
astonishing so um it's estimated that
between eight and 10 million illegal
immigrants have entered the United
States uh since Biden took office uh and
that's not an accident that's not just a
coincidence um and and you know that
that's a significant swelling of a of a
population of about 330 million people
um and that it's putting enormous strain
on not just border states but now
Northern cities uh like New York and
Chicago which simply don't have the
means of handling this many newcomers
without any resources uh it's costing a
fortune uh New York City in particular
is is in a quandry because uh not only
has it declared itself a sanctuary city
which means they don't enforce
immigration laws um it's another kind of
tension between the feds uh and and uh
other local
authorities uh but it's also got a
so-called right to shelter um and that
means that they are legally obliged to
put up anybody who doesn't have a home
and they have been applying the right to
shelter to not only New Yorkers who
become homeless but also just anybody
who rocks up uh I wish I'd known that
when I was
scraping as a as a postgraduate student
um would have saved me a lot of money uh
I and I don't I don't understand how
this continues um because it
will uh there's no there's no end in
sight of this flow of people there are
now
68,000 people in the in the New York
shelter system they've completely run
out of
room um they've actually had to cut back
on the budgets of all the other major
departments in order to finance uh what
I understand is um of what is it
$400 per night per household and by
household uh that includes single adults
a single adult will make up a
household uh I mean most normal
Americans couldn't couldn't afford that
and it's
just
astonishing now as much as I hate to say
this the only thing that is credible
going to bring a stop to this is the
election of Donald
Trump gosh and Li know I I know how much
it would pain you to say that it pains
me
fantastically why why do you think he
will succeed because looking at his
first presidency you know after reading
your piece I did have a look at how
successful he was but he actually he
failed to get illegal migration down
when he was president the first time
around ice actually deported um the in
2020 the fewest people ever deported
since 2003 when the agency was set up
isn't it just a pretty intractable
problem it's it's incredibly
intractable um and it comes down to
problems with the law and
outdated immigration statutes it's this
is the same in Europe right so the the
US has signed up to the same kind of uh
Asylum policy that Europe has been
pursuing and um it's ruinous and the
weird thing is that most of the people
who are being led in and uh are allowed
to apply for Asylum don't qualify even
under very loose definitions of of a
legitimate Asylum claim but in the
United States and this is not that
different from a lot of places in Europe
including Britain there's such a backlog
that uh if you've applied you may be
getting a court date five years from now
even 10 years from now which is going to
give these people assuming they show up
for the court date which is big question
um it's going to give them PE grounds
for remaining permanently because they
will have established you know uh
households probably had children uh who
are American citizens um you know
so while the admission is temporary we
know better it's not temporary but but
why would Trump be able to solve it
better I think um he will at least uh
change the rhetoric and I I'm really I
have to apologize for my tense because I
should have
said he might because we don't know that
he's going to be elected president
so um but in in let's say he is elected
he will put up a lot of
Bluster and there's there's certainly
going to be a
fear on the migrant side that you know
he he talks such a hard line all these
people don't know the statistics right
talks such a Hardline that you know it's
important to get in uh while Biden is
still president in fact that's one one
of the fears uh on on the administrative
front that uh the more it looks as if
Trump might get in then there's going to
be a big push for the border and the
irony of that is that it's a kind of
self-fulfilling prophecy in terms of the
presidency because as I note in the
column this is one of the determinants
of who wins the election uh there's a
huge uh anger in the country over the
kind of images that are coming up uh
being coming from the border and it's um
and it is changing people's votes it on
on a widespread level I mean it I'm not
uh I'm not statistically supported here
but I read a lot of comments and the
number
of uh lifelong Democrats that I
encounter uh in the New York Times who
claim that because of this issue alone
uh they're going to vote Republican um
that number is is huge and so I
I I think I think that a an even further
surge could easily uh push Trump over
the wine that's that's fascinating liono
and we'll be sure to stay on the story
throughout the election year thank you
so much for joining spectator
TV in this week's cover piece writer
Henry Jeff laments the decline of boozy
Britain what does it mean for a
country's health and economy if we're
all drinking less and what vices are
young people replacing alcohol with
Henry joins me now with the Times
restaurant critic jles Corin Henry and
jles welcome to spectator TV now Henry
it is January um so it's probably a good
time to be talking about this new trend
that you've uh identified that Britain
is sobering up tell us about what's
happening yeah well you know the the
young people just aren't keeping up
their side of the bargain you know
they're meant to start drinking at 14 or
or even earlier because there's not much
else to do and the signs are that
they're just not doing that something
like a quarter of young people are t
total or say that they're te total the
the rest of them are more concerned with
you know looking beautiful drinking
water going to the gym all that kind of
stuff than sitting in Parks drinking
cider and smoking Ben and hedges so it
was just a kind of a sort of middle
man's Cry of like you know what are the
young people
doing that's what it's all but it's not
just young people um older people are
drinking less as well so it's just about
the how the whole country is sobering up
like Henry I'm a man of a certain age
and excoriating the young is uh part of
my bread and butter but normally we
winge about how uh or in historically
it's about the young being feckless and
given to booze and drugs and shagging
and uh and nothing productive and not
knuckling down you know in our day we
well not our day quite but our parents
day one did national service and helped
all ladies across the road and had a
general sense Henry you seem to be
lamenting the fact that they're all
terribly well brought up and sweet and
kind and all the kinds of things our
parents wanted us to be uh while we were
down the bike sheds you know chasing the
dragon and swilling Hof
me I don't know what you were doing yeah
you went to slightly different schools
than me we were we were just smoking
cigarettes um yeah you know in some ways
I actually think that they've they have
it slightly better cuz we were you know
so there wasn't that much else to do in
the 80s apart from sit around and drink
cider I mean I went to to boarding
school and I was rubbish at sports if
you if you didn't play sport drinking
and smoking were about the only two
things you could do whereas I think
young people nowadays have vastly more
things to do most of them on their
phones and they can meet the opposite
sex online you know they don't have to
go to Sticky floor nightclubs called
vizage or cudos to get on with the
opposite but you in in you you are
lamenting the passing of something
though in your in your excellent article
aren't you you are saying that there is
there is you know something something
our way of life is not threatened you
and I can go and get wankered in the pub
till we die very happily doing the cross
word and uh eating poror scratching
going outside for a f and coming back in
for a for a shot and a chaser with so
what the kids are doing is not
threatening us but you are sort of
worried that they are losing something
by not
drinking yeah I think they are I think
there's a lot of spontan ious
interesting and fun things happen when
you when you add alcohol and perhaps put
down your mobile phone and also I worry
and this is probably um another slightly
middle-aged man thing that the kind of
Institutions that we take for granted
the kind of local pub um sort of you
know good quality wine available
reasonably cheaply need a healthy and um
W widespread drinking culture to support
them and if drinking becomes a minority
Pursuit then pubs will close and the
price of wine and whiskey and all the
sort of things we love will go up even
more than it's going up already well
they when when landlords and the and the
and the sort of the I was in the pub for
lunch only an hour ago and talking
actually to the landlord about a
favorite Pub of ours of devire in Demon
Street in SoHo which has just been
reopened by a legendary landlord off
Rogers and he doing fantastically well
and shipping out loads and loads of
Guinness and it's a great Pub success
story an environment in which basically
a quarter of pubs I think in your piece
it said have shut since whenever it was
2012 2013 a lot of that was said to be
to do with taxation rules and Duty rules
and booze becoming very cheap in
supermarkets and people who really want
to drink go and drink in a supermarket
and the loss of Pub culture is a
slightly separate thing isn't it than
from the actual people actually not
getting bladed
anymore um I don't know I think I think
it's the sort of getting bladed is a
slightly sort of side thing it's more
just the kind of re regular drink
drinking rather you know having drink as
part of your everyday life rather than
something unusual and isn't it the case
both that um it's not that the young are
necessarily turning away from alcohol
for healthier Pursuits you know you talk
about drinking water sure uh you know
going out for walks fine but you know
some of them are turning to things like
vaping you know things like weed we've
already mentioned uh or I don't I know
anecdotally some young people who you
know do lots of hard drugs but think
that they want to mix that with alcohol
because God forbid so it's not
necessarily better yeah the ones that I
know and I work in a kind of I use a
sort of shared office space in in SoHo
and so I there are quite a lot of young
people around or youngish people in the
20s and 30s it's not they don't seem to
be doing they don't do heroin and Coke
and stuff so much as as the
hallucinogenics they're the thing that
they think is great that's the thing and
I'm talking about people in their late
20s early 30s professional there's a
fellow I better not give him his real
name but there's an older tonian who's
working on a history book at this thing
he's he's Fant fantastic fellow sort of
tall and handsome with a long beard and
he was the other night he was off to he
was going to even song at St Paul's on
shrooms and he and a couple of friends
that's what they were doing they were
going to do a load of shrooms and then
he reported about the next day he'd done
too many shrooms and had to leave
because it was too freaky and he had to
go home and he was going to chill and
then go back to St Martin in the fields
for some Vivaldi where he was going to
do a spot of Molly which I believe is
what they call Ecstasy but in sort of
small doses while listening to classical
music and it's sort of on the one hand
way more daring than us on the other
hand pathetically Square yeah do you
remember that summer this is slightly
slightly off the point do you remember
the Summer where every single head shop
in Camden suddenly realized that
mushrooms weren't technically illegal I
think it was like
2003 and they all started selling magic
mushrooms but as ornaments so they would
say here are these magic mushrooms they
are do do not do not eat them do these
are purely ornamental and it lasted
about six months before people crack
down on the loop I know this is totally
irrelevant but it was a very funny
summer 2003 I think people who were into
drugs even when I was young so it's not
fair it's not fair man it's Babylon
booze is legal but you know cannabis is
illegal for no reason AP from white
people having control whatever and you
think I know what they mean but booze is
so woven into everything we do and as a
restaurant critic you know I I just
can't not drink it even if I were doing
dry even when I've tried to give up
alcohol I I feel so weird and wrong and
party poopy in a restaurant because sort
of it's w woven into what we do and not
not scary at all is it where whereas the
the drugs seem to be other and other and
you're sort of worried there might be a
shift where booze ceases to occupy this
generals this role that it always has
well that's the thing I mean I think you
just hit the nail on the head I think
things like restaurants pubs bars are
places where you have basically
controlled environments for intoxication
so if you want to take yourself out of
reality slightly rather than you know
taking shrooms and perhaps taking too
many and missing missing your drugged up
even song you go to the pub and you
drink your you know Cara of malbeck or
your pint of bitter and stuff and as
long as you stay off like the Jager
Meister shots you can kind of control
how much you drink quite quite well once
you reach a certain age obviously when I
was 16 I couldn't do that but you know
by the time I got to 30 I was pretty
good at measuring how much I could drink
and you have this environment and this
culture well you know like like a wine
tasting for example you know people go
to wine chasings they pretend it's about
the bouquet and the towar and the soil
it's not it's just a sociable way of
getting drunk in a sort of slow and
controlled way and I think if you if
people aren't drinking and you're not
having the younger generation coming
through that kind of thing will
eventually die out I I think you're
right those those kind of social
establishments would die out but on the
point about control you know me as I
hear it anecdotally you know there's all
about micro doing these days there are
these milligram uh scal that tell you
exactly how much you're taking Purity
tests that tell you exactly how pure uh
the stuff you're taking is so that
control thing is also changing is that
market changes now I want to ask you
both what do you think about the alcohol
free stuff like the alcohol free beers
that pubs are adapting to uh the
alcohol-free bars are totally alcohol
free but pretend to be proper bars do
you hate them what do you think I've
never been to an alcohol-free bar the
whole idea just makes me feel so sad I
don't have any problem with alcohol-free
drinks I just think at some point I'm
GNA want to have something with alcohol
in because the reason I drink beer is
because I like the taste of it but also
because it you know makes me feel like
I've just had some beer um so while I
actually quite like some alcohol-free
beers and do actually drink things like
Adams ghost chip and stuff on occasion
the idea of a totally non-alcoholic bar
I just I mean I wouldn't go I think I
feel similarly I mean I I don't fancy a
um an alcohol-free bar I don't really
like zap's product
uh it's like I've been I I did not drink
for about a year once uh and by the time
I've also tried being vegan and when I
was tried being vegan it's fine if you
eat fruit and vegetables if you eat that
sort of fake bacon they eat or their
veggie burgers it's disgusting and I
this was about 10 years ago and my wife
was pregnant with our second child and I
thought well I'll see what happens if I
if I don't drink and it was sort of
marvelous and I did drink then it wasn't
so good it was beex blue which was
disgusting but then beex is so
disgusting that the the Gap was kind of
small but it had a terrible sort of
aftertaste there were a couple of Vice
beer that were okay but what I needed
and this was about a year I did it what
I needed was I don't have a sweet tooth
I don't have so so there's something you
you've got to drink and with a meal you
just can't I can just about drink a Diet
Coke on a hot day but I couldn't with a
meal and water doesn't do a job so you
need something which sort of they I
always use the pH phrase lazily oh we
had a marvelous marvelous chabi that cut
through the grease and it's a it's a
thing that rest say but it is sort of
true you have to kind of uh you have to
kind of uh do s of clean off your tongue
with something that isn't sugary some
sort of drinky thing and I found most of
the earth thing ridiculous I it was
quite it was an Awakening not drinking
for for a year and I was thinking about
it when I was when I was reading Henry's
peace I at the beginning I couldn't
believe how much of my life I got back
I'd look in my diary and generally
speaking if I look in my diary now it'll
say Wednesday afternoon lunch with Bob
right well I won't do anything Wednesday
night and probably not much of Thursday
morning that's a write off Thursday
night dinner with the SE and so yeah
well Friday I'm going to have a terrible
hangover so we can't do anything then
you look at weekends oh god I've got to
take my son to football but the night
before I'm going to be absolutely
steaming and then when all that was
taken out the days were incredibly long
and I got more done I wrote a book part
of a book yeah I got Al the days were
just long and uh every S no day was a
write off the weeks were long you could
loads of stuff you felt amazing and then
the weeks got too long and then I
discovered there wasn't actually that
much to do and it would get to a
Thursday and I'd have done everything I
needed to do for the whole month and I
was wide awake and I think God I need to
be pissed now and that was in the end
the thing that I went back to and I
think that is the role that it fills is
we don't have particularly journalists I
mean I used to in the 90s on Fleet
Street we used to drink and drink and
drink and it was because Henry knows
there's not that much to do right taking
writing a piece it's a couple of hours
but you when you in the days when you
went to an office you had eight hours to
fill so you get in go to a conference
write a paragraph do your intro then go
to the pub for three hours and and and
get battered come back at 4: and then
it's exciting trying to get it done by
5:30 when you can hardly see with one
hand over your eye and and the keyboard
and that's the whole profession sort of
built up around that take away the booze
and you could hardly say papers are more
interesting now are they I don't know
what they're doing well I think we're
spending a lot more time on Twitter and
YouTube nowadays Charles and Harry I'm
afraid I've got to leave it there but
thank you so much such a pleasure to
have you on the
show Royal journalist Robert Hardman
writes all about the new look monarchy
in this week's spectator Charles is a
keen mushroom picker he says and Prince
William is planning to shorten his own
coronation service to just over an hour
down from his father's too to tell us
all about it Robert joins me
now Robert Hardman welcome to spectator
TV um now you've got a new book out
Charles III new king new court um and
before we go into all of that I mean
we've also found out this week that the
King has come down with some health
issues as well as Kate so what do we
know about what's happening well yes
it's it's um been quite a uh an unusual
start to the year in the in the space of
a few hours it was announced firstly by
Kensington Palace that the Princess of
Wales is in hospital recovering from
surgery and we'll stay there for a
couple of weeks um will probably be out
of action up until Easter and the king
is going for a routine operation next
week in connection with an enlarged
prostate um and will be out of action
for a few days so I mean there's nothing
to particularly worry about but I mean
the fact that these these both these
announcements came so close together uh
I think is a reminder of um actually you
know we hear a lot about this the
so-called slim down royal family and and
and you know two absolutely key players
are not going to be out of action for a
while yeah abely we wish them all the
best and you know I'm sure they'll be
back in Action soon enough yeah we wish
them all the best um now Robert you talk
about this new king and this new court
you know and you talked about the slim
down monarchy as well um what Mark has
King Charles made on the monarchy so far
he's only been in position for one year
well it's been an extraordinary year and
a bit hasn't it um and I think a lot of
people at the start a lot of his critics
particularly were sort of voicing fears
that he would um might be a bit of a
loose cannon he might overstep the mark
he might might sort of speak out too
much um and actually what we've seen is
a a very
shooted
um confident and and crucially happy
this is the thing he's a happy Monarch I
found this while I was writing my book
and following him around he's very kind
of content in in in in the position um
and uh and and it's it's I think now you
know as as going as as well as anyone
would have dared to expect because you
know there was a lot of talk about how
do you follow on from the most uh
revered and record-breaking uh monarch
of all time um I mean Elizabeth II was
was adored and and enormous shoes to
fill um and yet he's done it and I think
he surprised people because he hadn't
really talked about it much while he was
Prince of Wales largely because he just
felt it was
inappropriate um and there hadn't been
any kind of jostling for position you
know he was very content with his role
as Prince of Wales and he adored his
mother and that was that um but the time
came he's he's taken it on uh and so I
think possibly what what has not
necessarily helped the monarchy but it's
certainly enhance the idea of the
monarchy as as being a sort of stable
force of continuity it's just a sort of
Madness of the political situation so
you know in the same time as we all
remember there was that week where we
had you know effectively uh well had two
prime ministers and two monarchs in the
space of three days um and yet it was
the uh the Royal part of the equation
which has been thoroughly solid and
steadfast the political side of course
has been all over the place and still it
yeah and and you talk about this happy
Monarch and how you went to Boral as
well and one particular um tidbit I
think we can say from that is him
foraging for mushrooms tell tell us
about that so the King goes into the
forest and picks his own mushroom he is
a mushroom picking King he loves picking
mus I think he finds he loves planting
trees and he likes he likes gathering
fruit and mushrooms whatever whatever
the time of year but particularly in the
Autumn he's very keen on picking
mushrooms and as I say in the book I
mean on the day the queen died he had
managed to fly up to see her been to her
bedside he'd gone back to his home at
Burk Hall a few miles away for a few
hours nobody knew at that point that the
queen was going to decline as rapidly as
she did and he was out in the in the
grounds picking mushrooms and and and as
I say in this week's spectator diary and
in my Royal notebook um yeah when the
when the sunx came to stay and every
tradition that the Prime Minister and
spous come up for a weekend usually in
the Autumn to stay at Balmoral and and I
happened to be there because I was
researching my book and my my TV program
and so watched them arrive and you know
we went went for a walk in the grounds
with the king and queen and it was it
was you know actually it was very nice
weather it was sort of rather Charming
late late summer Summer's we can um yeah
and at one point the king just
disappeared to go and pick mushrooms for
his guests uh and I think everybody
thought that's a very nice gesture
although as I say in spectator this week
um one or two people think well is that
such a good idea should the Monarch
actually be picking mushrooms for the
Prime Minister because you know if if
things went wrong and it it has been and
I have mentioned in my piece that you
know occasionally these there are these
terrible accidents where somebody picks
the wrong thing and you could end up end
up in a very serious situation so uh as
one privy counselor said to me I mean
just imagine you know you could have
lost the king the queen and and also
staying with some some eminent friends
including the Provost of Eaton so um
yeah I just raised the question of you
know should should should they all eat
the same thing to which I think you
answer is yes of course they should but
it's it's quite an interesting thesis
well I assume he knows his mushrooms he
does um and rather explosively in the
book you also reveal that the queen was
not at all happy about the naming of
Harry and Megan's daughter liliet which
is the Queen's nickname and that's not
what we' heard before Harry had said
that she was supportive it wasn't wasn't
the naming of of of of their daughter
Lili but that was the issue it was the
handling of the story that then unfolded
because they' let it be known that she
supported it she was it was basically
put around she given it their B her
blessing um and then the BBC reported no
that's not what happened she wasn't
asked and there was a sort of big um uh
tussle between the be and the sussex's
team and then um the sussex's issued
legal proceedings and um went to the
palace and said well you you'll back up
our version of events at which point
there was a residing silence um
because we don't know precisely who said
what to whom but this idea that the
queen had given her blessing clearly did
not sit with the palace and the queen
doesn't she loves Harry she loves liil
but that that's unchanged um but no one
um rearranges the Queen's words if you
like no one says that the queen said
something if she didn't and that was the
source of the anger the fact that um the
queen was being asked to um uh should we
say endorse a version of events that um
was not in her view what happened and uh
to in the book I just say it's another
case of her probably one of her most
famous lines of her long Reign
Recollections may vary and presumably
she was uncomfortable with the force of
the law that the Sussex has brought with
that you know the threat of suing
considering
her I don't I don't you know it's this
is a book on Charles III it's not a book
on the sussex's I you know I it was an
interesting uh Discovery um I think
possibly we can all overread you know
too much into it and and after all we
are dealing with you know who said what
to whom um in what order um some time
ago um but there's absolutely no
question that the uh the the the queen
and the palace were very unhappy with
the way the subsequent story was handled
that was the root cause of the of the of
the row you talk about the political
turbulence over the last year it's not
also not just been political because in
the royal family there's also being a
lot of turbulence not least coming from
Harry and Megan's Direction um how has
King Charles dealt with that you know
the the publication of spare the
six-part Netflix documentary you oing
his first year of being monar his
youngest son you know that's pretty
tough it I it was an extraordinary start
to a Rain ready that in the space as I
say in the book it was a 3month
concentrated period of pretty negative
headlines on a weekly if not daily basis
you don't forget you also had another
series of the crown coming out and that
was a particularly um helpful either so
you had the crown uh Juggernaut going in
in October of 22 very soon after that
you had the sussex's own six-part
Netflix series and all the attendant
publicity that went with that and as
sooner as that then we were into the
whole sort of spare production with the
the the interviews ahead of the
publication of spare as as as Harry's
book was called um which was a huge
Global bestseller so all that's happened
in a fairly concentrated period right at
the start of his Reign and you might
think well that's a pretty that's a
pretty difficult start but actually what
he did he just got on with it um there
was no there was no fight back there was
no sort of counter briefing uh you know
we in the Press I think would have liked
to have he heard uh more um more noise
coming from the other direction um
particularly particularly from the Duke
of from The Prince of Wales from Prince
William um who clearly was was very hurt
by a lot of this stuff but uh the the
decision was we're just going to get on
with the job we're going to ride this
out we're not going to do any sort of
briefing and and it just sort of passed
and I think the reason that it it passed
is that um while people obviously
desperate to read you know Harry's book
and and his Netflix series did very well
I don't think really changed anyone's
perceptions or views on the monarchy if
you were a um a Sussex die hard you're
more Die Hard than ever you feel
absolutely pumped up by this stuff if
you were a Sussex critic you thought oh
look at them there they go again um I
think most people the majority of people
just in between they just think well we
have heard the story before I think you
know the fact that Harry and Megan were
not very happy being Royal I think we
kind of got that message got that
message a year ago maybe two years ago
um and and they've now been in a I mean
they're they're Royal existence as a
royal couple it was something like 6 or
700 days they've not been in a post-
Royal existence for well over a thousand
days so you know that that the story can
only be told so often and I think we've
sort of heard it and and monarchy has
escaped relatively unscathed under you
are yeah and you ask you know what what
is what's the king's view on on on on
all this and I think we in the media are
sort of slightly guilty of constantly
thinking he must you know lie awake at
night always thinking about the dramas
of uh you know wither Harry wither
Andrew
uh and actually there there's just so
much else goes on when you're a monarch
there's just all the day-to-day stuff of
you
know what what a ministers doing who who
who needs to be appointed to the privy
Council what state visits are coming up
where do I need to go which regiments
haven't I visited for the last year um
what there a whole I mean it's a lot of
um
unresolved Royal uh baggage that needs
to be sorted out this year and sorted
out quite quickly there's a whole issue
of the patronages all the patronages
effectively got put on hold following
the death of the queen and there's been
this huge reorganization going on and
that needs to be that has yet to be
announced the whole issue of Royal
warrants you've got literally hundreds
if not thousands of well hundreds of
companies employing thousands of people
for whom having a royal warrant is a
very important impr premata it's what
what what is key to their a lot of their
sort of marketing marketing strategy
they want to know what's happening with
our our warrants and all these things
they they get done very carefully I
suppose it goes back to the point of who
said what and why you know the palace
takes you know the who said what to whom
very very seriously is everything has to
be um has to be done very precisely um
they don't want any Loose Ends so all
all that all all these various strands
of uh of Royal life in a new Reign have
got to be resolved and that that's in
some cases many cases that has yet to
happen so he's got a lot on his plate
which is why if from time to time there
is uh you know there there are more
grumblings from Monte Cheeto well you
know there we are Robert Hardman thank
you so much for joining
TV and finally can a war be just if lots
of civilians die Oxford University's
Nigel biger writes about this in the
magazine this week in war civilian
suffering can be moral and legal he says
Niger joins me now Niger biger welcome
to spat TV now if anyone watching the
war unfold in Gaza I think they would be
horrifying by the scale of the civilian
destruction um but you write in the
magazine this week that it horrific
scale doesn't tell us anything about it
morality or it legality tell us about
that no you're quite right the the scale
of human suffering in Gaza is is um
awful um but the fact is that that um
War involves a lot of tragic human
suffering um the laws of War uh do not
prohibit the killing of lots of
civilians um the laws of war War
prohibit the intentional killing of
civilians and the disproportionate
killing that's to say killing that is
not necessary to achieve um a an
important military
objective um um and and the reason the
laws of war are permissive in that way
is because you can't fight a war
successfully without risking civilian
casualties often and certainly during
the second world war the Allies um uh
cause Grievous harm to civilians not
because they wanted it not because they
intended it uh but because there was no
other way of fighting the Nazis
effectively so you're saying if you
think that war needs to happen then
civilians sometimes need to die I I'm
I'm afraid so not not in every case but
but but usually that that that is the
case um I mean if you're a pacifist then
of course no casualties military or or
non-military are are acceptable morally
if you're not a pacifist um then uh
you're going to have to accept there
will be a lot of tragic deaths and the
World War II example is really
interesting I didn't realiz realiz until
reading your piece just how much
civilian lives were lost can you tell us
about that yeah so so most people in in
the west certainly in the English
speaking West think that the war to um
defeat genocidal Nazism in Europe was
morly justified but a conservative
estimate has it that Allied um that's to
say British and American bombers killed
uh around 350,000 German
civilians uh now that that's
controversial of course because the
British particularly under bom Harris um
um may have um deliberately intended to
to kill German civilians which was was
immoral um but uh they didn't intend to
kill 70,000 French civilians which is
what uh happened in France U during the
second world war and during The crucial
uh Normandy campaign the invasion of
Normandy in 1944 around 30,000 friend
ofans were killed why was that because
the Allies depended very heavily on the
use of of bombers and
artillery um and they didn't have the
precise techn the technology that
allowed them to to Target
precisely um they didn't want to kill
civilans but they couldn't avoid it the
alternative was to to expose troops on
the ground to Greater
risks um problem was that as early as
1943 the British were running out of
men so so it was felt that that um the
priority is to defeat nacism and we have
to take risks with civilians but that's
the moral gray area isn't it I mean I
can see why intention is very important
but isn't there also um a point about
negligence you know are you as an army
doing order that you can to minimize
civilian casualties or are you valuing
your own soldiers lives more than that
of civilians and where does that ratio
start to become very questionable well I
mean one has to one has to um put it to
the likes of the Israeli defense for in
Gaza U are you really uh being as
careful with civilian lives as you
possibly can that's a fair question to
put um uh the answer has to come in
terms of the circumstances uh uh we have
there's no as it were general rule here
the question is what is what is it
you're trying to achieve militarily what
means are you using uh could you use
means that would expose civilians to to
fewer risks is this military objective
really important uh but depending on the
answers the answer could be uh we can't
minimize civilians any any further uh
and we have to pursue this military
objective um even at the cost of
considerable civilian casualties I think
it's fair to say that the world is
watching this conflict you know so many
uh countries in the developing world are
very concerned about this and that's why
South Africa has recently brought a
genocide case against
Israel but these but they're raising
this kind of questions aren't they we
can't just take the idf's word for
saying that they're minimizing things
what happened on October 7th was so
deeply traumatic for them um there has
to be questions raised by impartial
people outside of Israel no absolutely
uh but in order for a criticism of um
Israel to be cogent in order to make the
case that Israel has intentionally
targeted civilians in order to make the
case that the exposure of civilians to
to harm has been disproportionate or
genocidal uh you need to have military
experts who understand military
operations you also need to have people
who know the facts on the ground um but
but granted granted military expertise
and granted knowledge of what's going on
on the ground yes questions need need to
be put to Israel as to any uh any
country that is Waging War uh but as for
genocide um uh I mean you're right uh uh
South Africa has brought a a case of
genocide against Israel in the
international criminal court
um but I I think it will fail because
the uh 1948 genocide convention
stipulates that genocide takes place
when there is an intention to destroy a
people in whole or in part as such right
so so the idea has to be that Israel
wants to exterminate
Palestinians not that Israel is risking
Palestinian civilians in the course of
pursuing military objectives against
Hamas and if there is evidence of
genocidal intent then let's see it I
don't know there is any such evidence
and I what about duty to find
non-military Solutions you know
obviously Israel was thrown into this
conflict by the attack of October 7th
but can you can we really say that
Israel has exhausted all non-military
options to solve the Palestinian problem
before October 7th and doesn't that have
implications on how just this war is no
that's a really important Point uh Cindy
so I think Israel is Justified um in its
immediate military reaction to October 7
Israel has to defend its people against
um um uh indiscriminately murderous
violence um but um in the long term
Israel's military operations have to be
part of a larger strategy for
peace and I don't know what that is um
uh uh about 10 years ago there was a a
film uh released called The
Gatekeepers um um it was actually quite
riveting although it only comprised
Talking Heads but the Talking Heads were
of Grizz old Israeli Security senior
security uh um Chiefs and one after
another they said know we're in the
business of of uh preempting terroristic
violence and and stamping on fires and
we can keep on doing that till the cows
come home but what's the strategy yeah
and they said there is none this was 10
years ago and and my sense is uh Israel
doesn't have a strategy for peace other
than simply containing Hamas and Gaza
and undermining uh the Palestinian
author Authority so um um whereas I
think the the the the the shortterm
military action of of Israel is
Justified uh the question of um
prolonged military operations purporting
to achieve a final permanent solution to
to the problem uh that has to be part of
a larger strategy which involves
non-military means and I think Israel
needs to be needs to be asked what what
that strategy is well the thing that
reminded me of um was Israeli uh
president Isaac Herzog said last year he
said that there are no such thing as
innocent civilians in Gaza that it's
entirely a nation out there that is
responsible I mean that's a kind of
thing that would demonstrate that at
least the civilian militant distinction
is not drawn by Israel in the same way
that maybe International observers are
drawing it well I mean to some extent
the president is is is correct in that
particularly in the case of an
Insurgency um such as as um hamas's
recent operations are
uh um um precisely because insurgents
hide themselves or or mix themselves up
with civilians it's very hard to
distinguish uh nevertheless
notwithstanding that um it's still the
case that Israel needs to uh focus on uh
um destroying Hamas or disabling Hamas
and not Exterminating Palestinian people
um uh so I think that sanction still
needs to be made whatever
it's very hard to judge to what extent
this civilian or that civilian is
involved militarily with Hamas some will
be some will not be you certainly can't
say that all Palestinians are are are
colluding in hamas's um um U Warfare
well N I think this is you know the Crux
of the issue here I mean it's such a
horrific conflict and nobody wants to
see it as destruction but this is
absolutely the Crux of the moral issue
so thank you so much for joining
spectator TV thanks for having me
on that's it for this week
once again if you enjoy spectator TV do
subscribe to our YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon so
you never miss an
episode thanks again for watching and do
join us next
[Music]
week